former Destiny's Child singer Michelle
Williams is taking some time for herself
the 37 year old singer opened up on
Instagram revealing her decision to seek
professional help her statement read in
part quote I recently listened to the
same advice I have given to thousands
around the world and sought help from a
great team of healthcare professionals
she added quote I proudly happily and
healthily stand here as someone who will
continue to always lead by example as I
tirelessly advocate for the betterment
of those in need it's my love and I
think that's that is my calling my thing
to do as far as being inspirational in
my way keeping hope Michelle's post
didn't explicitly state what she's
seeking treatment for but she's been
very honest about her battle with
depression in the past I've disclosed my
depression in the year 2013 to the plane
of I was suicidal I was I was to that
place where it got so dark and heavy et
was with Michelle in 2013 shortly after
she initially revealed her mental health
struggles there were times in depression
where I could stay in the bed all week
and I would just maybe get up to use the
bathroom or something but it's like girl
you got to get up
honey get fabulous curl your hair put
some lip gloss on and do something you
have to choose life you have to choose
it nothing is just gonna mystically drop
out of the air and you're gonna feel
happy you know what I mean you have to
choose it